we have had yet another major
development in the conformation of
Donald Trump Supreme Court prick pick
Brett Kavanaugh the Senate Judiciary
Committee has decided to postpone this
week's vote on Kavanagh and instead
they're going to be holding a public
hearing about the sexual assault
allegations against Kavanagh six more
individuals also say they have stories
to tell about Brett Kavanaugh but I'll
talk to you about that a little bit
later on in the program this is
fantastic news it's fantastic news and
simultaneously exposes pretty serious
problems with our political system which
I'll get into in a moment but
nevertheless I told you yesterday that
it was unlikely that these sexual
assault allegations would straight-up
torpedo Brett Cavanaugh's confirmation
but that it was increasingly possible
that they might at least delay it
because yesterday Lisa Murkowski became
the third Republican who said she thinks
we need to slow this down not have the
September 20th vote on Brett Kavanaugh
and figure out what on earth is and
isn't the truth when it comes to these
sexual assault allegations against
Kavanagh so first of all this is Major
okay don't be tricked by the right into
thinking that this is no big deal
because this is a major interruption to
the confirmation process a process that
has already started so this is this is a
major thing and don't don't be tricked
into pretending that it's not secondly
Christine Blasi Ford's accusations are
credible and they're concerning enough
that people on both sides of the aisle
are saying hold on a second let's go
through this a little more carefully
this is an appointment for life
Ford herself is going to testify and
hopefully this will get at the heart of
what allegedly happened between Brett
Kavanaugh and Ford the 30-ish years ago
three decades ago you don't always get
to hear directly from the accuser in
these high-profile situations and here
you will now the obvious question is
well what's going to happen Kavanagh is
going to show up very prepared he is no
doubt
you have crafted a credible enough
sounding story so that Republican
senators can say listen he showed up he
didn't seem deceptive they will show up
very ready to make Christine Blasi Ford
seem as incredible as possible and in
all likelihood they'll hold the hearings
and they'll say we did it we feel good
now we are ready to move forward and we
can't think of any reason to hold up
this nomination any further so now the
key becomes what else happens between
now and then these hearings tentatively
scheduled for next week if more women
come forward between now and then if
something else breaks then that could
change and indeed there are six
additional people who want to speak
about Brett Kavanaugh and I will tell
you about them in a little bit so I'm
glad this is happening don't get me
wrong I am disgusted however that it
took this to slow down a process that
should have been interrupted a long time
ago and what I mean by that is the
following we have endless thousands of
documents about Brett Kavanaugh that
have not been released that have not
been made available to senators who were
supposed to vote on this confirmation
and yet the process continued we had
extraordinarily concerning non-answers I
would say answers but really they were
non answers from Brett Kavanaugh to
Senator Kamel Harris about whether or
not he had been in touch with people at
the law firm that was involved at which
the lawyer that had been defending
Donald Trump in the Moller probe worked
very very concerning that should have
put a complete and total stop to this
confirmation process and yet it
continued and then we found out that
Brett Kavanaugh had lied under oath
multiple times at prior confirmation
hearings and still the confirmation
process continued and now finally it's
this that puts a pause on the process
it's a warranted pause don't get me
wrong but the pause should have happened
a long time ago I hope that Christine
Blasi Ford is ready for what's coming to
her because it's going to be truly too
disgusting Donald Trump jr. has already
been mocking her on Instagram and this
is going to scale up big-time once she
actually sits in front of senators
during that public hearing about this
they are going to try to Annie to Hill
her need a hill of course sexual
harassment accuser against then Supreme
Court nominee Clarence Thomas as I told
you yesterday and it's going to be a
truly vile sight to behold
so let's play out the path to no
confirmation for Cavanaugh what would
that look like there are a few
Republicans on the fence right now it
only takes a few to vote no in the full
Senate and the confirmation doesn't
happen and the most likely scenario if
it will not happen is that enough
Republicans say in advance I'm going to
be voting no and they never actually
have that vote and Cavanaugh withdraws
in advance Donald Trump withdraws
Cavanaugh from from that process it's
actually a possibility now a week ago it
seemed that it was a foregone conclusion
that this was going to be the next
Supreme Court justice for life it's
still sort of an uphill battle there's
one other direction that the hearing
could could take or could be used for
which is the hearing could be a pretense
to say we took it seriously and now it's
time to move on and confirm Brett
Kavanaugh it could very very likely go
that way and my assumption is that
that's exactly what many Republicans are
thinking I'm worried that this is going
to take the focus off of the more legal
related issues and make it simply an
adjudication of do we believe a sexual
assault allegation from 30 years ago
which in the end is going to be he said
she said in character witnesses many of
whom dozens of whom have already come
forward saying Brett Kavanaugh is just
an absolute great altar boy nothing
negative we could say about him so the
focus from Democrats should be on
Cavanaugh committing perjury and not
having endless thousands of documents
about him and all of that other stuff
but this is what we now have this is
what is now interrupting the
confirmation process and we should see
it through to the
which way do you think it will go is
what I want to hear from you about
particularly after I give you an update
about six other people who want to talk
about Brett Kavanaugh today's program is
made possible in part by better help.com
slash Pakman this is something I really
believe in better help gives you access
to fully licensed and experienced
psychologists and therapists through
your phone or computer I have been
talking for years about the problem
around people not seeking help because
of the stigma around mental health
services because of the cost of mental
health services and all you have to do
with better help is go to better help
calm slash Pakman answer some basic
questions you'll be matched with a
therapist that will be right for you
you can change therapists if you don't
think that it's a good fit it's less
expensive than seeing someone in person
you will still get the professional help
and it is unlimited you can talk to a
therapist every day from home or
wherever you are go to better help calm
slash Pakman it is so easy to sign up
and get started we've put a link in the
description if you're watching on
YouTube better help calm slash PA que ma
n if you've been wanting to talk to
somebody but for whatever reason haven't
please go to better help calm slash PA
que ma N